[Musique]
confier sa mine de plomb
pour moi continuer pour commission les
des mois de septembre un petit p
[Musique]
je
il des
jeunes
raison
avec des
[Musique]
mu
ça partie client plaisir
ouais
nous avons des richesses et d'artistes
du groupe est de trop sur ce département
est donc
consacré d'énergie
et sur l ont fait
les collectivités sont indispensables
parce que justement elles permettent
cette volonté de culture de proximité
partout sur les téléports va continuer
ça avec alain pichon ça fait partie de
nos engagements une de volonté ce sont
des petites bulles de partager des
petites bulles de bonheur dont on a
besoin et qui est voilà recommencé hier
c'était entrant ce soit à champigny
samedi prochain à vivonne et puis
j'espère preneur occasion de se voir
passer une bonne soirée taxi
[Musique]